[موسيقى]
كنت تتحدث على الهاتف وكان والدك
يسمعك وأعتقد أنه كان بإمكانك
سماعه أيضًا ، هل يمكنك التحدث عما
حدث في النهاية لأنك
بقيت على الهاتف لفترة طويلة ،
نعم ، لذا فإن الممرضة في
لحسن الحظ ، عرضت المستشفى أن تأخذ هاتف المستشفى الخاص به
وأن تضعه بجوار
أذنه ولم يستطع التحدث معك حقًا
ولكننا سمعناه وهو يتنفس ولذا
كان لدينا وقت معًا تمكنت من
دمج جميع مكالماتنا على هذا الهاتف  خط
وهكذا تمكنا من مشاركة الكثير من
ذكريات والدهم وإخباره
كم كانت تحبه نوعًا ما من الهتاف له ،
يمكننا حقًا سماعه وهو يتألم ولكن
مجرد سماعه وهو يتنفس كان مثل
علاقتنا به وأنا كيف  كنا نعلم أنه
لا يزال على قيد الحياة ، فكم من الوقت بقيت على
هذا الهاتف ، لقد مر أكثر من 30 ساعة.
أعلم أنها
كانت مكالمة طويلة حقًا وكنا جميعًا
في أماكن مختلفة في  العالم الدنمارك ،
كارولينا الشمالية ، تكساس وولاية
نيويورك ، كم منكم كان على المكالمة يا
هوراس ، يا له من شيء غير عادي
أن أمي ماتت في الصيف الماضي ،
وتمكنت أنا وعائلتي من
أن نكون معها في  النهاية
ومعها طوال الوقت ولكن من المهم جدًا
أن يكون هذا المعنى أعني
أنها تجربة غير عادية وعلى
الرغم من أنه من الواضح أنها مختلفة
على الهاتف لتتمكن من الحصول على ذلك الوقت
لتتمكن من قول كل الأشياء التي
تريد أن تقولها  يجب أن
أعني أنه في وقت ما ، يبدو من الغريب أن
أقول ، لكن أعني أن هذه نعمة عظيمة
إذا كان المرء يمر بهذا الأمر ، فقد كانت
نعمة كبيرة ، فقد سمحت لي بالحصول على
نوع من الإغلاق كما تعلم كما قلت إنني
كنت قادرًا  لأقول
إنني بحاجة إلى معرفة أنها كانت النهاية ، وعلى
الرغم من أنني لم أتمكن من رؤيته ولم أستطع
إمساك يده من خلال هذا الاتصال
عبر الهاتف ، فقد كان ذلك مفيدًا للغاية بالنسبة لمرضى
[الموسيقى]
الذين خرجوا من
الجانب الآخر  فيروس كورونا يسميهم مدمجين
تلائم المواد الخطرة
أنها تُعرف باسم الأجسام المضادة ، وفي الوقت
الحالي هناك دافع
لفحص أكبر عدد ممكن من الأمريكيين بالنسبة لهم ،
الاختبارات التي يُنظر إليها على أنها ضرورية
لإعادة الأمريكيين إلى العمل عندما
تحاول معرفة ما إذا كان الشخص
مصابًا أم لا.  اختبار نتحدث دائمًا
عن اختبار الأجسام المضادة ليس هو
نفسه اختبار الأجسام المضادة لفيروس كورونا القياسي ،
وهي بروتينات طورها
جسمك عندما تصاب
بفيروس مثل كوفات 19 لمكافحته
إذا تعافيت من فيروس كورونا ،
تبقى الأجسام المضادة الخاصة بك.  وإعطاء جهازك
المناعي ذاكرة عن الفيروس ، لذلك
إذا تعرضت لفيروس كورونا
للمرة الثانية أو الثالثة ، فإن تلك الأجسام المضادة
التي تطفو في دمائها
ستتعرف على هذا الفيروس
ونأمل أن تحيده ، فكيف يمكن
اختبار أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص  من الممكن
تحديد من لديه أجسام مضادة ضد
فيروس كورونا ومن لا
يساعد في فتح الاقتصاد مرة أخرى أولاً عن طريق اختبار
الأشخاص بشكل فردي وإعطائهم الفرصة
للعودة إلى العمل
يمكن لهذا الشخص إنهاء التباعد الاجتماعي أو لا ، ربما
يجب أن يكون هذا الشخص عاملاً في الخطوط الأمامية
ولكن أيضًا عن طريق اختبار مجتمع بأكمله أو
على الأقل الحصول على عينة تمثيلية
لاختبار الأجسام المضادة في المجتمع قد
يخبرك أن مجتمعك قد
أصيب بشدة بفيروس كورونا هذا
وهناك الكثير من مناعة القطيع مما يعني أن
الكثير من الناس قد تعرضوا لهذا
الفيروس ومن غير المرجح أن يجد هذا الفيروس العديد من
الضحايا في مجتمعك بعد
الآن ولكن اختبارات الأجسام المضادة في الوقت الحالي ليست هي
الرصاصة الفضية التي ستجعل
المحرك الاقتصادي لأمريكا ينطلق مرة أخرى على الأقل
ليس بالسرعة نفسها  كما يريد الرئيس ترامب
ذلك لسبب واحد هو أنه وفقًا
لأحد دعاة الصحة العامة ، فإن الكثير من
اختبارات الأجسام المضادة التي تم تجربتها
لا يمكن الاعتماد عليها ، فإن الخطر في هذه
الاختبارات إذا لم تفهم
الجودة هو أنها قد تمنحك
خطأ  يمكن أن يمنحك الإيجابي سلبيًا خاطئًا ،
فأنت لا تعرف مدى
دقة ذلك ، ويمكنك حقًا تعريض الأشخاص
للخطر من خلال منحهم الأمر
يمكنك السماح للأشخاص بالعودة
إلى حياتهم في حين أنهم في الواقع
لا يزالون مصابين بمشكلة أخرى
وهي عدم وجود اختبارات كافية للأجسام المضادة
على الرغم من أن د.  يقول أنتوني فوسي
وغيره من كبار مسؤولي الصحة إنهم
يحاولون نقلهم إلى السوق في
أقرب وقت ممكن
، ولم يوافق دا دا بعد على أي اختبارات للأجسام المضادة ،
لكن الوكالة تسرع من
عملية المراجعة من أجل الحصول على
الاختبار للجمهور في أقرب وقت.  لا يزال
من الممكن أن تمر أسابيع أو حتى أشهر قبل
أن تصبح الاختبارات متاحة على نطاق واسع براين
تود سي إن إن واشنطن
[موسيقى]
وأحد الأسباب التي تجعل الرئيس
ترامب يفضل مزيجًا من الأدوية التي
نتحدث عنها ، آمل فقط أن
يفوز رجل الدين الهيدروكسي إلى جانب ربما
z  -pak كما نسميها ولكن يوم الثلاثاء أوصت
المعاهد الوطنية للصحة
بعدم الجمع بين
هيدروكسي كلوروكين وكما لو كان من خلال
Meissen والمضادات الحيوية تباع أيضًا
كحزمة z ما لم يكن المريض في تجربة
إكلينيكية قائلا إن هناك احتمالية لحدوث
سميات في White  إحاطة مجلس النواب
مساء الثلاثاء ، أوصت لجنة من الخبراء في
المعاهد الوطنية للصحة في الواقع الآن
بعدم استخدام هيدروكسي كلوروكين في
تركيبة مع z-pak والتي  هو
شيء أنت بخير ، هناك العديد
من الأدوية الأخرى التي تجري دراستها لمعرفة ما إذا
كانت ستساعد مرضى كوفات 19
مثل عقار REM المضاد للفيروسات ،
لم تصادق لوحة Nih على أي منهم قائلة إنه
يجب إجراء المزيد من التجارب السريرية
والآن يحتاج الأطباء  التخطيط لدراسة
فئة أخرى من العقاقير ، تلك التي تعالج
جلطات الدم تقريبًا ، كل
شخص أراه يُطلب مني
إجراء مقابلة معه وفحصه لديه مشكلة تخثر
مع داء كوكاكولا الحاد
، ومشاكل التخثر ليست
الأكثر عمقًا في ذلك  لقد رأيت من قبل في
غرفة العناية المركزة ، ممثل برودواي ، نيك كورديرو ،
أصيب بفيروس كورونا الجديد
وبُترت ساقه بسبب
جلطة دموية نجا منها ، لكن الجلطات الدموية يمكن أن تكون
أطباء قاتلين يحاولون اكتشاف
الدواء المناسب لمنع هذه الجلطات
بطريقة أخرى  إنقاذ حياة
مرضى فيروس كورونا الجديد
إليزابيث كوهين تقارير CNN
[موسيقى]